y aquí está el resultado de la votación
watson juanca votos 334 emitidos 307
mayoría 154 a favor 214 en contra 93
tras una caótica revisión el proyecto de
ley para imponer el pase de vacunación
en francia fue aprobado en la asamblea
nacional según este texto las personas
mayores de 12 años tendrá que probar que
están vacunadas contra el kobe 19 para
acceder a actividades de ocio como
restaurantes y bares ferias e incluso el
transporte público ya no será suficiente
una prueba negativa salvo para el acceso
a establecimientos de primera necesidad
y servicios de salud el proyecto de ley
pasa ahora al senado con lo que se prevé
que habrá un retraso para que entre en
vigor es 15 de enero como estaba
previsto el presidente de manuel macro
fue criticado por haber dicho el
miércoles en una entrevista que
remetería contra las personas que no
están vacunadas contra el coronavirus
el objetivo de esta ley no es disminuir
la circulación del virus en nuestro país
el objetivo de esta ley es perseguir a
los no vacunados
a vacunarse es decir condenarlos a una
especie de muerte social si no aceptan
vacunarse
hoy a los ojos de la opinión pública
ahora está claro que este fase de
vacunación no resuelve ninguna manera la
contaminación sirve como señuelo para el
gobierno para ocultar sus andanzas la
propuesta del gobierno llega en un
momento en el que la variante o micro en
el coronavirus ha elevado los contagios
diarios francia supera desde hace una
semana todos los récords este martes por
ejemplo hubo 332 mil 252 nuevos
contagios y hay cerca de 5 millones de
personas que todavía no se han vacunado